[Applause]
40 million gamblers walked to the Vegas
strip each you but most people only get
a peek at the spectacle that is Las
Vegas to see it all you need to be a
high roller willing to spend $100,000 a
hand someone like Don Johnny he's a
blackjack player who lives the life of a
rock star when Don Johnson walks in a
club dancers show off his initial and
celebrities pay their respects
the scene is all engineered by the
casinos and they pick up the tap so
whatever you want they're going to try
and customize a package if the player is
big enough they're going to try and give
him what he wants what it takes to
dazzle everybody today is a hundred
times more ambitious complex and
challenging than before Steve Wynn's
always inventing new temptations to lure
gamblers nightclubs to shows - celebrity
chef restaurants we've trained the
public and raise their expectations a
good thing but only players like Don get
aimless treatment the best tables the
most expensive bumps the catering to
high-end players starts before they even
think about coming here they'll bring a
player from the east coast to Las Vegas
the MGM property has the mansion which
is 29 villas under a climate-controlled
don't and you get to stay for free well
nothing's free it's all factored into
the game I'll give you a little secret
inside baseball on casinos now Jim Miran
is the CEO of MGM he owns 10 Vegas
casinos and Dunn is getting parked at
every one of them let's say you're gonna
spend about a thousand dollars we're
gonna win theoretically $200 I can
compute to induce you to come out here
I'll give you about $80 worth of stuff
and the more money spent the more money
casinos make now move the math up to a
whale if the whale is gonna
theoretically lose $200,000 I should be
willing to give him $80,000 with the
stuff but we can't eat that much caviar
you know even if I fly you from point A
to point B I'm probably not burning
eighty thousand dollars worth of fuel so
the margin on the high-end the margin on
the whales is higher which is why
casinos will do just about anything to
keep the whales plane
you